the acting White House chief of staff
says President Trump didn't expect so
much opposition to his plan to host next
year's g7 summit at his Florida resort
the president now says he will not host
the gathering of world leaders at his
Doral resort in South Florida acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney faces his
own pushback for acknowledging the
president held up military aid to
pressure Ukraine to investigate
Democrats Paula Reed is at the White
House Paula are there signs at Mulvaney
who is acting chief of staff might lose
his job entirely Tony a former White
House official tells CBS News the knives
are out for Mulvaney and his press
conference last week drew criticism from
both sides of the aisle but so far
there's no sign the president is unhappy
and the Trump campaign has embraced
Mulvaney's messaging even selling a
t-shirt with Mulvaney's now-infamous
quote get over it
I still think I'm doing a pretty good
job as the chief of staff and I think
the president agrees acting chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney insisted Sunday he
is not stepping down absolutely
positively not in an administration
known for upheaval Mulvaney's role seems
less certain after an explosive press
conference last Thursday get over it
there's going to be political influence
in foreign policy Mulvaney undermine the
president's impeachment defense by
confirming a quid pro quo in why aid to
Ukraine was held up three issues for
that the corruption in the country
whether or not other countries were
participating the support of Ukraine and
whether or not they were cooperating in
an ongoing investigation with our
Department of Justice I'll leave to the
chief of staff to explain what it is he
said and what he intended Mulvaney
recanted his statement but his
performance exemplified how the White
House has failed to offer a coherent
defense against the impeachment inquiry
if you held up the money for three
reasons that was that's a quid pro quo
I'm not acknowledging this through his
it again let's go back to that three we
go back to the UK I recognize that go
back to what actually happened in the
real world Mulvaney's name has also
emerged in the impeachment inquiry
itself a former presidential adviser
testified that Mulvaney worked with the
president's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani
on a rogue operation involving Ukraine
Mulvaney's quid pro quo admission last
wasn't the only thing Republicans were
having a hard time defending it was also
the president's decision to award
himself a huge contract by hosting next
year's g7 summit at his hotel in Florida
this just creates more controversy that
quite frankly we don't need right now
mr. Trump was not expecting Republicans
to criticize the decision and in a rare
move he reversed course on Saturday
night the president will need all the
Allies he can get as Democrats ramp up
their coordinated messaging strategy
today House Democrats are releasing a
fact sheet and a video containing the
most damaging evidence they've gathered
so far and their impeachment inquiry
Gale Roy Paula unless you're cutting a
nice juicy steak never good to hear the
knives are out when they're talking
about your job thank you very much we'll
talk to you a little bit later on